yeah you had a really weird experience
right joe because you you had a cat as a
kid right yeah something like that i
became allergic to cats i had three cats
and you became allergic and then i
became alert so it was so weird so like
i had so when i was born i had one cat
uh called marble right she was really
cute and then she she died shortly after
i was born because she was quite an old
cat
and then we got two more cats because my
parents just [ __ ] love animals like i
was surrounded by animals my entire life
yeah so i had these two cats little guy
in pocky um and i had them till i was
maybe like 10 or 11 years old yeah and
then
just completely coincidentally
like two weeks after
my last cat pocky had passed away i was
gonna go get an allergy test
right because i'd never got one in my
life so my mum was just curious being
like i wonder if you have any food
allergies or you know medicinal
allergies or whatever and because it's
free in australia right so it's like
yeah [ __ ] it let's go so i went to go
get it and then i did the test and i
remember specifically there was one part
of my arm that was really [ __ ] itchy
yeah i was just like oh [ __ ] like yeah i
definitely have an allergy towards
something i don't know what it is and
then the doctor came in they were like
yeah so you're allergic to cats
and i was like
that doesn't make sense i had a cat up
until two weeks ago yeah but the doctor
explained that apparently it's like a
thing where if you're surrounded by a
certain allergenic for your entire life
and then suddenly it gets cut off your
body has like a whiplash effect
where you can actually develop an
allergy for i again i'm not a doctor i
don't know how actually let me tell you
let me tell you what happened joey yeah
your body was like i will never love
another cat again yeah
i am not allowed to love any more cats
dude
that's honestly probably what happens
which sucks because i [ __ ] love cats
and it's like and and now like you know
over time like i've just grown to like
get allergic to like all sorts of
different animals do you feel any like
of a itchy nose when you put your like
face into cuddle at all so okay so for
dogs
and some other animals it depends so
like with dogs i'm allergic to some
breeds
but not others i'm probably okay with
cando
because normally i would be sniffling
like a [ __ ] right now but i've
gotten pretty close to him already like
he was sitting here just a moment ago
and i'm completely fine okay yeah so i
think i'm okay with him but like some
other like long-haired dogs for instance
the moment i entered like it got so bad
to the point i remember in high school
where i went to a friend's house for the
first time and i started sniffling
outside of his house and i said do you
have a dog in your house and he was like
yeah how did you know
because i because i'm [ __ ] dying
right now superpower yeah like my
sinuses are getting destroyed right now
and so i could tell immediately
yeah i like i just i used to i i have
hated cats for so long and only recently
have i met a couple of really sweet cats
and i'm just like oh my [ __ ] god oh i
mean like wrong i don't
join the club
it was so [ __ ] annoying i was like oh
you're just the sweetest little baby and
i love you it was like a little stray
that we found and then we like we got a
new home but we had to give him away
because i would i put my face into him
and he was like drooling on me and i was
like i don't [ __ ] care
get out of it and your face is like
[ __ ]
i was like
that's rare because like 99 of the time
cats are [ __ ] they are [ __ ] they're
such [ __ ] creatures but there's
something about them where you just like
it's because i'll forgive you yeah it's
a hard level game the reason why people
like cats is because if that cat likes
you and nobody else
i'll tell you what it is cats are just
catches just the tsunderes of the anime
right right right you're like you
[ __ ] they [ __ ] why do you want a
dog you should have a cat
i want a cat as well honestly like i
don't know i'm not that's like a syndra
dog yeah yeah yeah that's why that's why
i wanna shiba actually yeah i don't know
it's just like i i get it because like
you know they're like [ __ ] moody
teenagers a lot of the time like cats
right they're just like they just do
their own [ __ ] but then the moment they
show a slight bit of like love towards
you yeah yeah yeah yeah
your little [ __ ]
actually actually there's uh we uh in my
house in england uh we have like the
neighbor has a cat right but it like
comes into our garden so often
that uh me and sydney just like we
didn't know what his name was so we kind
of just like gave it a name right yeah
yeah so i don't know why how does name
came about well we just started calling
her scarlet joe
this poor cat has an identity issue
so i don't know who i am yeah and
initially initially she would come over
and she'd see us and she was like
[ __ ] scuttle off or something and
then and then slowly but surely like
she'd come over to our like garden so
often that you know we you know we
started like trying to give her a little
bit of attention at first she was like
no get the [ __ ] away from get away from
me get away from me all right right and
then and then like what happened was we
moved to thailand me and sydney moved to
thailand right
and
uh and after we had come back to england
for like for like a quick trip we go
outside
and then scarlett joe just [ __ ] bolts
it towards us to be like oh oh my god
where are you i'm like that was the
first time we were able to pet her and
we were
and then we were able to pet her for
like a full five minutes and then she
was like all right i don't like you
anymore
the honeymoon faces yeah
but it happens like it happens every
time now where we go away we come back
to england yeah and she sees us she's
like for the first like for the first
meeting she's like so excited and i'm
like yes i live for this i live for this
you totally just reminded me this is the
most australian story i have but we had
that exact same experience in our
neighborhood right but instead of a cat
it was a rock wallaby
what's a rock wallaby so think of think
of a kangaroo but like miniature size
and it's just these like wallabies that
just like that like they just hop around
in the forest like along like rocks
right like structures and we had one
because like i live right next to like a
national park yeah so it was like just
my backyard was a national park so like
every now and then we would just see
this rock wall be on
it like on the street
and be like oh that's like oh that's
really cute you know but you know but it
was no biggie right because it's like
national parks right there you know
whatever but then like the more i saw it
the more it would like get closer to me
yeah and get more comfortable with me
even though i wasn't doing anything
right i was like
yeah i would walk yeah i would have
walked back home from school and they
would just be like the rock will be i'm
like oh you're a lot closer than last
time so i'm like maybe i can hit him
maybe
i can muster up the energy to pet him so
i remember one day yeah i was as i was
coming back from school same [ __ ]
rock wallaby like hops over i was like
i'm gonna go towards it
i'm gonna i'm gonna try my chances but
like because it's a rock wallaby right
they're really [ __ ] like cautious
they're like the squirrels of australia
yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] mini
kangaroos yeah
like squirrels are kind of the same
thing where they're like sometimes
they'll come close to you because
they're a little curious they'll never
let you pat them but they'll never let
you pay yeah yeah yeah so i was like so
i got close and it was it'll be like oh
step back [ __ ]
like we're cool but we're not that cool
yeah yeah you know but then eventually
it got to the point where i got one pet
in
and i was like
yes
it was the best feeling and i was like
mom can we can we have the wrong one
with me i want it as a pen
but uh yeah you can't do that in
australia unfortunately but i remember
that you're addicted to the to the to
the the energy of petting like we just
love animals
you were saying before like australians
just are good with animals
i feel like you have to be to survive
though you know that's that's like not a
symbiotic relationship yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly
it's like we won't [ __ ] with you as long
as you don't [ __ ] with us that's what it
is yeah every time i'm like scrolling on
tick tock and i see some australian guy
[ __ ] with like a like an animal yeah
he's like he'll have like a full-on
tarantula on his leg and he'll be like
oh you're right matt you're right all
right sometimes these guys get a little
bit in your house you just go let him go
he's like put him down you know he's
like all right see ya and then everyone
in the comments like what a [ __ ] gig
a chat
he's just the stranger
you guys are like that [ __ ] what are
those like [ __ ] guy like creatures
called in like avatar
whether like have to be like one with
nature right
sorry
wait what kind of adverts are you
talking about like
james cameron james cameron
because i [ __ ] love avatar and i want
to be in it that's the blue that's the
blueprint
i'm excited for
are you the reason james cameron is
still like i promise there's gonna be
four of them oh four okay like the only
thing that i think okay i love the idea
of aliens and just like leaving and then
dipping and i love the old like i mean i
build fairy houses i love nature like i
want to have a property and like live
out in the forest you know this is like
my jam on steroids obviously it's going
to be bad
i'm still going to watch it because i
hope it's not bad because he's hyped
this [ __ ] up more than anything the fact
that just the anime i just want to see
what people are able to do with like the
animation and everything nowadays yeah
well i mean the other movie that he kind
of helped with uh
the anime adaptation movie that he
didn't direct but he had he kind of
helped what's the one oh love death and
rose no no no no no
what was the anime with the girl with
the big eyes
that's what yeah leader like that was
like i think he worked a lot with the
people who did it uh and so i think if
it's that good quality a leader was
really [ __ ] good looking
yeah
yeah it looked good
i didn't see it so they look [ __ ]
awesome it was all right i mean it was i
liked it i thought it was really good it
was it was a good film what i want them
to do is i want this stuff to go well
with this kind of animation so they
could redo the world of warcraft movie
completely animated
and they can redo the halo
series completely animated
i mean the halo one was rough i
look does halo even have a good
storyline to adapt actually yeah it kind
of does it's kind of a sick one i've
never paid attention to it it's a really
cool world concept
yeah it's a shame they turn into this
[ __ ] mediocre [ __ ] fest they just got
to take chief actual cheese yeah and
like animate little tiny cortana and
like all that stuff and then yeah yeah
there's a lot of politics in halo like a
lot a lot of politics it works right now
orbiter is [ __ ] sexy yeah
ryan has the mark of shame on the back
of his legs no way
oh yeah i could love all the arbiter
memes
i think it's time to finish